200 years of the HUD vogner celebrating
a genius in the interview opera director
catalina vogner hello Katarina vodka
thank you for making time for us shortly
before your great-grandfather's 200th
birthday we're in a very special space
here also called lost space there are a
lot of them in Berlin like this
abandoned bakery what fascinates you
about these deserted locations fasting
nyet see I agree so on Diesel's own
affair lassen and I think ultimately
it's connected to stage design what's
fascinating is that you can find a lot
of elements for set design you can take
interesting photos that can't
necessarily be translated one-to-one
into stage design but if you were a set
designer you say that's an interesting
image and then something develops from
that they're just great locations where
you can really take great photos I take
a lot of photos privately to of
interesting locations and places like
this are part of that this is a great
location
can you imagine staging a performance in
a place like this in Opera musical
theater I can imagine it but on the
other hand you know what the legal
restrictions are like I'd have to see
what the authorities would say if you
wanted to put something on here fire
escapes that kind of thing as
great-granddaughter head of the festival
and director you're involved with the
works of the Chad vogner pretty much
around the clock are you still able to
look objectively at the work of your
great-grandfather that's a difficult
question I think the problem is if you
grow up with something like that and are
so familiar with it then you can't
really say you're impartial because
you're so familiar with the material you
grow up with it and it's simply a part
of you to that extent the familiarity is
just so big of course you can try to be
as impartial as possible or to view it
as critically as possible that's a
different issue but the familiarity is
an inevitable part of having Const
contact with it would you create
distance for yourself you also work as a
director so if you're staging a work by
a great-grandfather what are the
interesting aspects for you there you've
done so much of it so often already
Sofia runs off come back I think that's
always the question for a director what
interests them about a work what's
relevant for me about this work right
now what fascinates me
I don't do historical productions for me
every day every moment every change can
play into a stage production as a
director I can't negate the past or what
is happening in the present and I think
especially with vogner's works it's
about basic elements of the human
condition basic characteristics such as
jealousy power love hate those are
natural things that will always somehow
be current as long as Humanity is around
I think that works are very contemporary
because they reflect on what are simply
basic human traits as long as humanity
survives these issues will be very
interesting Rock know anyone around the
world can enjoy vogner's opera with
excellent performers why should they
come to buy white first of all because
bicoid is a very special place the
Festival Hall simply has the world's
best acoustics at least the most unique
acoustics but in a totally positive way
if you your posse fall there you feel
the music from all around from under
your chair the side from above it's
really an acoustic miracle on the other
hand you've got an excellence in via
voice defined by a certain atmosphere
the people go and look forward to it
give up their holidays we shouldn't
forget that the working conditions are
quite unique people want to work and by
height that makes for outstanding
quality and really good rehearsal
conditions for instance we can usually
offer rehearsals with original props and
scenery not rehearsal sets
you can really see the benefit and the
artistic result and as I said people
come to buy Hoyt because of the positive
atmosphere and they want to spend their
vacation there you really noticed that
and how the special atmosphere is really
good for the art for the end result
let's talk about the legend of iolite
I know you're not a fan of the
mystification of the location is the
bicoid festival just a festival like any
other I think it's more what I was just
referring to first if you look at it
objectively we simply have really unique
acoustics and that's one reason why the
house is unique and of course it's
special for a composer to have an opera
house built just for his own works
that's quite special I also think that
the location and the pleasure people
have and working there which is really
completely voluntary is also hugely
beneficial it's really fun and you see
that in the artistic result you acted as
a child on the festival hall so you've
pretty much grown up with the works of
your great-grandfather and the entire
vaak no family history was there ever an
option not to become a director or not
to become director of the bicoid
festival well the option was always
there but I was just too interested in
it all my parents never pushed me and
said you have to do this it came from
watching especially the directing the
questions were always how would one do
that differently how would one do it
oneself it was a completely natural
process over the festival in 2008 with
your half-sister Ava what's changed has
your view of bicoid and the whole
festival change
I think the structural changes have been
fairly serious there's been a change
from one proprietor our father to three
publicly owned shareholders and one
private shareholder the change to a
limited company as the legal entity has
brought with it a lot of changes and
they're still really in the adjustment
phase
yeah in medical science fastened so
cause as great as the fascination for
the music of the chat vana is around the
world there's also a great deal of
skepticism in Israel for example his
music remains unaccepted historians
accused the family of continuing to
hinder research into the involvement of
the Nazi period how are you dealing with
that unfortunately we can't always
control that because we don't have
everything to control it with but of
course we do try to make things
accessible to the public as much as
possible and for my part that's what
I've done things are being put into the
archives so that they are completely
accessible but of course there is still
material in the family that belongs to
all the heirs and this is an important
part of course I cannot decide alone
what happens to that material what kind
of materials I don't know I don't have
access to them there are rumors that
it's correspondence between vinified and
Hitler you promised to do something to
work on clearing that up but not much
has happened well for my part where I
have access something has happened
I've spoken to various archives and the
materials will be going into our
archives soon again the problem is that
when it belongs to four heirs I have to
reach agreement with them because it's
not my sole property so I can't say I'm
going to throw this at the feet of the
public tomorrow I have to see that
everyone's pulling in the same direction
and then make the material available
most coking of Allah and I'm strong as
material often laying down that requires
a lot of patience if it were up to me it
would all have been publicly accessible
long ago is the biggest innovation
you've made so far
oh god innovation is such a big
word you know if someone brings a new
medication onto the market that's
innovation so I think we shouldn't get
too carried away 90 where you think I've
done that I've changed that that's
different an innovation in the arm world
I think we've done a lot of wonderful
things but the word innovation should
affect humanity in a different way
certainly one nice thing is the
children's opera and that's been really
successful it's a great opportunity and
artistically we're trying to do it at
the highest level another great thing is
vogner in the cinema a live broadcast
that can be watched in movie theaters
those are great things of course
starting in 2016 I think you can say
you'll really see what Ava vog Naposki
and Catalina vogner have done in the way
of innovation then I think you can use
the term innovation but otherwise
innovation always carries a great weight
I think from 2016 you'll really see what
we're responsible for and of course we
hope that we found good artists May 22nd
is Alicia vogner's 200th birthday
there's not an opera house in the world
that doesn't have his works in their
program how are you and by Hoyt
celebrating it celebrating the
anniversary with a birthday concert in
the festival hall which is a big
exception because normally we only ever
have performances during the festival
season it means a huge organizational
effort for us because the new ring is
rehearsing on the stage right now that
means we have to take all that down and
set up for the concert the ring
rehearsals have to be interrupted so
it's really a big deal putting on a
concert like that in a year with a new
ring production all the musicians will
gather together and we'll rehearse under
conductor Cristian telemon last question
the bicoid festival only lasts six weeks
what do you do the rest of the year I
twiddle my thumbs no seriously this year
in particular we've got the early works
three complete operas in partnership
with Leipzig
we've got Rienzi and by Roy with
Cristian Telamon in the Oh both honking
ho and you can imagine that's not an
opera house but we're building a proper
opera house into it
there'll be proper theatre stalls you
can't imagine the logistics involved the
home will be completely blacked out
acoustically and remodeled there's going
to be a proper stage so there's really a
lot to do because we're turning a fairly
basic events venue into an opera house I
haven't just been working on that for
this past year but for the last three
years it's a crazy amount of work but we
wanted to have the three early works in
bicoid in the Jubilee year that was our
big wish because they've actually never
been performed together like that so I
need to be having good thank you you're
welcome